wouldn't it be cool to have realtime
conversation with my data well let's say
I work in sales and I am trying to
understand sales patterns inventory and
promotion plans so here I am in looker
which companies typically use to explore
and visualize data to make Better
Business decisions now with the new duet
AI features I can just type show me
total sales from top five seasonal
products
globally and duet does its magic it
understands not just what I'm asking for
but also what I'm trying to achieve now
what it does behind the scenes here is
it uses data models metrics and big
query tables in context to generate
answers and it knows that the demand
forecast and inventory levels are the
next things that I would like to explore
so I click on demand for forecast and
great now we know what are our top
selling products that are at risk of
stocking out which is our coolers and
sunscreens and the ones with too much
inventory which is our umbrellas and
sunglasses duet didn't just give me data
it gave me actionable insights with
visuals and now I can pass on this
insights to our procurement team to
stock more products and to our
promotions team to Market our Surplus
inventory with just one click I can send
all this information in an automatically
generated slide
presentation how cool is that